today's challenge is an easy what your
eyes open master sneezer students needed
a student sneezer so you guys don't know
there's like this up apparently it's a
myth that you can't sneeze with your
eyes open
now I genuinely believe that season with
your eyes open and most acts like
impossible but a couple years ago couple
years ago this may prove me wrong you
could sneeze with your eyes open without
eyeballs popped out and it takes extreme
focus extreme focus
it's so scared than my last one doesn't
throw up on all of them as you can see
weapon of choice has been prepared you
could use a tissue you can use a napkin
you can use a paper towel whatever you
want to prep it basically just rip the
end of a corner just roll that [ __ ] up
like this it looked like a joint you
know and basically you got to pick the
size based on your nasal cause it was
the length of it you know different
strokes for different folks right so we
have various sizes set up right here and
we're gonna do the [ __ ] right now we're
gonna do two [ __ ] we're gonna show you
how to sneeze with your eyes open I hope
she gets a nosebleed I hope you fart
when he says we have to get quite we
have to get quite because this requires
extreme focus you got to think about a
lot of things you got to think about how
it's going to feel when it comes out so
you got to stay quiet you got to stay
focused right so we'll start so
basically a spot you're trying to hit is
the inner corner because that's the
g-spot
no that's oh my god embrace it embrace
it don't fight it that's what you need
right whoo laughs man I gotta stay
focused it's better than at work yes I
feel [ __ ] good here next Oh go let's
go wait sighs good yeah extreme focus
okay refocus I know about that spot that
you're talking about yeah exactly it's
right in the corner gonna be gentle with
it I hate it you gotta be gentle
you [ __ ] day with yourself don't you
hahaha goddamn [ __ ] hold on hold on hold
on talking no talking just focus just
focus on
see as a professional oh thank you Brian
if it open don't close it don't close to
keep it open
I need the [ __ ]
yeah you gotta get it to like the lab at
least you got yourself to sneeze my head
I've never dug this GG to my nose before
you look like you just can't resist it
impact of life is like much that right I
think you like pop the blood vessel oh
yeah when I feel like I know it I nail
it yeah exactly
you watch you glad they go like oh [ __ ]
I just touched the bunch of what ends it
look like he's cat his dick suck right
Christmas okay you ain't ready
no you're better staring at you I can
write hey it's like oh good I'm not even
sure of this challenge and we just ended
up this night we decide to do it so it's
called the [ __ ] sneeze with your eyes
open challenge so if you guys are going
to do this uh be very careful and safe
yes remember make the tickler tickle the
g-spot make that face and it just needs
with your eyes open places do this
[ __ ] video attack because I just want
to laugh
it's not fair I'm talking to you
upstairs are you there
you know I can so please don't tell me
that this is an empty Oh
this is